these fans ready baby
everybody's right yeah good afternoon
glad you're here my name is Jerry doe
treated the Dean of the Mario Jacob Elie
School of Business and I'd like to
welcome you to our leadership
Institute's distinguished leader
presentation we are very glad to hear
first an announcement before I forget it
because always I've always wanted to
make this kind of announcement please
turn off your cellphone's
this is being taped by c-span it is
being we have a live feed going over to
the library for the overflow so I ask
that you do turn off your cell phones
and there with some nap I'd like to
thank you for joining us today and our
president president Farish is here along
with the vice president's were also
joined a special guests Mario gabelli
who is of course the namesake of our
school of business but also he was our
distinguished leader speaker in 2011 so
it's great that Mario was able to join
us today to honor his friend Lee
Cooperman
mr. Capelli and mr. Cooperman go back a
long way to the days of Columbia
Business School 45 years ago so we're
very glad that Mario who's our speaker
last year at this event is here to help
us welcome Lee Cooperman to campus
mr. coupons leadership in the financial
world is without peer really I mean I do
know that he kind of doesn't like the
term legend but he and Muriel gabelli
are legends in the field of Finance I
heard it on CNBC so I know it must be
true that we have two legends here and
we're very proud of that he spent 25
years at Goldman Sachs and retired from
his position as chairman and chief
executive officer of Goldman Sachs asset
management in order to organize his own
private investment partnership Omega
advisors a hedge fund
mr. Koopmans you know devoted 45 years
to the investment industry financial
industry he's a senior member and past
president of the New York Society of
security analyst he doesn't he said the
earlier of meeting today he doesn't
particularly like talking about himself
but he he really needs to because he has
a really incredible career and also I
want to point out that not only is a
leader in the world of finance he's also
a leader in the world of philanthropy he
is I was reading an article from The
Wall Street Journal about him and it was
entitled giving others a chance at the
American Dream and I thought that really
struck a chord with me because he talked
in that article about he feels that he
lived the American dream and he has
devoted a good part of his life to
giving others the opportunity to pursue
the American dream he is he and his wife
are signatories of the Giving Pledge a
public commitment started by Warren
Buffett and Bill Gates that commits
billionaires to give away a majority of
their wealth to charity he's taking a
lead in that he's a longtime donor to
the Columbia Business School he's a
recipient of the American Jewish
Committee Humanitarian Award the Seton
Hall humanitarian of the Year award the
Boys and Girls Club of Newark award for
caring again he's just you know
a real leader in both fields he has a
bachelor's degree from Hunter College
and MBA from Columbia Business School
and importantly an honorary Doctorate
from Roger Williams University so it's
my pleasure to welcome Lee Koopman
I think better without the jacket so I
thank you very much for that gracious
introduction like I hear injections like
that I think I got to keep in reserved
my obituary but it's a pleasure to be
here particularly since I was asked by
one of my great friends Mary gabelli and
Mario asks you deliver because I know
when I asked Mario he delivers that's
the essence of a good friendship I found
over the years at sessions like these
are valuable to you as the quality of
your questions so as you see when I
develop measurement my background a lot
of different areas we could touch on I'm
going to leave it to you don't hold back
I'm very open no secrets so I'll be
happy to respond to any areas that you
would like me to develop more thoughts
on as the cover sheet shows that I'm
going to talk a little bit about life
hedge funds and the investment outlook I
think probably the most important thing
I can talk about his life because you
know I've spent 45 plus years in the
business world and at the age of 69 and
being an investor for about 45 years I'm
entitled to be a bit of a philosopher so
given my diverse background I could
respond to your questions from a number
of vantage points first I'm a poor kid
at the South Bronx and that became
successful so I could speak to the issue
of being poor and being rich and that's
an easy one rich is better second
I've been a cell side research analyst a
cell side the portfolio strategist I
call them pontificate errs and the chief
investment officer of a major money
management organization for the past 20
years so I could speak to being in the
brokerage business selling research
services to people in the buy-side and
that could speak to being the buy-side
where I am presently thirdly I was a
director excuse me in shame with you
what a committee of automatic data
processing for 20 years so I can speak
to issues of
corporate governance and Tsar bucks
sarbanes-oxley and lastly I've had a
large number of philosophical anthropic
involvement s' spikey so I can speak to
a view towards philanthropy and really
it's been a great trip for me from
humble beginnings in the South Bronx my
dad may rest in peace was a plumber in
the South Bronx to where I stand here
today very similar I got an edge over
Mario in this humble category because I
was a first generation board America
Mario technically was the second
generation missus I guess as a
grandfather died in the coal mine in
late 1918 90s I believe and your dad
went back to Italy and and then but was
born in America so but Mary was equally
success and deserves all success but I
think describing my trip from the South
Bronx to here I should be an inspiration
to all of you as I say this with a great
society that with an average IQ a strong
work ethic and a heavy dose of good luck
you can go very far I started my journey
going to public school 75 in the South
Bronx I then went to Mars High School in
the South Bronx and then I graduated to
the West Bronx I went to Hunter College
City University of New York now called
Lehman College I spent four very happy
years there I've met my wife of 48 years
and our French class and our sophomore
year and given my skills at language I
would probably still be a hunter if it
wasn't my wife helping me in French I've
always had probably languages and after
this presentation so you probably have a
problem with English upon graduating
from Hunter I worked for about 18 months
for Xerox Corporation up in Rochester
New York and then I returned to New York
to Columbia Business School where I got
an MBA and that opened the door to Wall
Street so you know my first observation
is whether it's right or wrong getting
an advanced degree is what improved my
credentials open the door to Wall Street
I'm sure goldman sachs is tough enough
probably not to recruit necessarily at
the undergraduate
and so that MBA opened the door to
Goldman Sachs for me I myself prefer
PhDs working for me but that would stand
for poor hungry and driven because I did
not learn my drive from Columbia or hunt
or something innate I guess you learned
from your parents ever since it was
introduced to the marketplace I have
used this was true I used it this
morning
the men's cologne called obsession by
Calvin Klein and frankly that is the
word I would describe my to use to
describe my approach to the business not
only is investing my vocation meaning
I've earned my living but it's my
advocate and investing to me has proven
as a means of supplementing my income so
it's all-consuming and a shorthand
translation in my case would be the
harder I work the luckier I got and I
would say that hard work has never
killed anybody and I think to be
successful in your chosen field of
endeavor
be prepared to give of your binder of
your body your soul to achieve that
success I show the people that work for
me this slide for those of the back that
may have trouble seeing it it's a simple
slide makes a lot of sense right every
morning in Africa gazelle wakes up it
knows it must run faster than the
fastest lion or will be killed and every
morning a lion wakes up and those that
must outrun the slowest gazelle it will
start off at death's and it doesn't
matter whether you're a lion or a
gazelle when the Sun comes up you better
be running and it may sound numerous to
you but I tell my people there's a
message there and in my industry
basically roughly speaking if you allow
me to round off there are 10,000 mutual
funds many of which are very competently
managed it will manage your money for
less than 1% or less let's say and there
are roughly 10,000 hedge funds that
request some variation of either 1% of
2% margin fee and 20% of the profits as
their enumeration so assuming for the
moment your clients and not mullets
meaning fools
and our clients aren't we have some of
the most sophisticated clients that have
money with us if they're going to pay
you some variation of two-and-twenty and
can get the exact same performance pre
fee from a 1% manager
there's no reason they're gonna be
investing with you so if your client
comes with you basically they're coming
with you because basically they think
you'll outperform that when the market
is doing well you figure out what to do
when you make more and when the markets
underperforming in a defensive mode
you'll figure out what to do and get
hedged and get defensively postured so
what I say when I look at the slide I
tell my people this is you know you're
always got to be in the balls of your
feet no resting on your laurels if you
want to get paid more
you got to produce more and simple as
that and if you're not prepared to give
her the body in the mind you're probably
in the wrong business now these are some
of the elements of philosophy that I
have I think they're the right
philosophy and I think I want to share
them with you because it took me 45
years to develop this philosophy and I
see a lot of young nice faces in the
audience so I want to impart this
philosophy to you early on in your
careers
so Andrew Carnegie said around 1900 I
wish to have as my epitaph hair lies a
man and I would insert in today's age or
woman who was wise enough to bring into
a service men a woman who knew more than
he okay and so one of the great secrets
is the success in my opinion is to rat
to surround yourself with the most able
capable people and don't be threatened
by them but be benefited by that and
over my career I have been very
fortunate to have in my service men and
women that made me better than I was and
I was able to hold on to them because I
probably shared the fruits of our labors
with them I created the business I
raised the money but I understand the
importance of having quality people at
your side and so I probably share you
know the benefits of my business with
people that work with me my personal
philosophy of life I summed up about I
guess is now four years ago when I took
my entire family at that time
have two sons 4643 there were a little
bit younger four years ago my two
daughter laws my at that time two
grandchildren now I'm looking at three
but three and done I like them so much I
like that more but I can't control that
I took them all away for an
all-expenses-paid vacation to a hotel
and I explained to them that
statistically a male that survives aged
65 one average lived to 82 so the good
news if I'm average I have about 13
years left that's not a very comforting
number I might add and the bad news is I
really lift 75% of my life lodging front
of computer computer terminals investing
but I gave them four observations that
about life that I would give to you and
that is number one there was nothing
more important and family they root for
you and care about you the most
so stay close to your family and they're
all circumstances second and I really
consider Mary one of my great friends
but say to have it's great to have
friends but to have friends you know you
have to know how to be a friend so be
trusting friendly and supportive of your
friends extend yourself whenever you can
in the words of Ralph Waldo Emerson the
only way to have a friend is to be one
and I think that's very important in
life
third I told my kids never do anything
in life that F what you did appear in
the front page of The Wall Street
Journal in New York Times that you would
be embarrassed live your life as an open
book and that's the best way to conduct
yourself and finally which is going to
seem very remote to the vast majority of
in the audience is because it's far down
the road when you have achieved
financial security and success share
with others less fortunate than yourself
there's a biblical sense we are our
brother's keeper and I think we have a
moral obligation to help others in need
and so you know over the years I've read
a lot of words of other people that have
struck me in a command that impressed me
better within words that I could make up
so I've used the words of others so a
William Lynn felt I don't know any of
these people by the way I know Henry
Ford I know he was
no the other people the first test of a
gentleman his respect for those who
could be of no possible value to him
let me explain I've seen over the years
people that treat very nicely people in
a superior position to them but are
nasty to people below them that could be
vote absolutely no value to them is what
Phelps said to say and I really detest
that kind of behavior
so my view conduct yourself in a manner
respect people no matter what they could
do for you whether above you in life or
below you but treat people with respect
and dignity and I don't gonna come back
and basically reward you in many ways
Henry Ford said the best way to make
money the business not to think too much
about making it Warren Buffett who's
more of a contemporary when the merrier
than I you have great respect for he
says you know go to work for the people
you respect admire tap dance to work
don't worry about the money everything
else will take care of itself
and you know we're all economic people
to a degree but I think it's a very good
advice because you're not gonna really
do well with something you don't like so
find something you like do with people
you respect and admire and hopefully the
rest will take care of itself I'll skip
the Chinese proverb but it's worth
reading but William Ward I try to google
him and I found that there about 50
William Ward's on Google I don't know
which one but I thought his words were
really very succinct and something I
believe in you know before you speak
listen before you write think before you
spend earned before you invest
investigate I do that most of the time
before you criticize wait you know words
hurt before you pray forgive before you
quit try before we tire save and before
you die give and I think that's a very
good sequence of advice now I have a
granddaughter believe in that who's a
very poetic and very into the nonprofit
world she just turned 14 she's been
writing poetry she ages 7 she just came
back from two weeks in Santa Fe New
Mexico in a educational two weeks for a
terrible giving and chattable involved
in the communities and my family was
Jewish and hearsay that I am this is
Rabbi Hillel famous rabbit safe enough
for myself then who will be for me if
I'm not for others then what I am am I
am i for not now when
and my granddaughters Courtney and these
were her answers and I believe in them
if you're not for others no one will be
for you if you were for others and
others will be for you you show others
how to be for more than only themselves
and they will therefore be for you the
time is always now so now whenever so I
would say the relevancy to you because
you know giving is probably not
something you can afford to do now
financially you are in a very very
competitive world today and one of the
things you should do hopefully you want
to do out of your own initiative but at
a minimum to improve your resumes and
your competitiveness in the world is try
to find community activities that you
can get back to to distinguish your
resume from the next person because
people like me are getting resumes in
every day in this difficult economic
environment from five baits and from you
know high-class standing people with 800
SATs that are looking for a job and what
you got to do is find a hook on your
resume and to the extent you show a high
sense of community service and
involvements on top of good grades that
may be something a way of distinguishing
yourself from the rest now oh so you
want to go into a field that you have an
aptitude for as I said that you're not
going to succeed at something unless you
have an aptitude so I thought I would
put together a list of characteristics I
look for when I interview people and I'm
sure Mary we can add to this list as
well but basically you know a desire and
commitment to be the best a strong work
ethic you know Here I am you know the
introduces as a legend and I keep saying
to myself you know what legend does not
have an alarm clock that goes over 5:15
in the morning to drive to Jersey City
to take a 629 boat around the tip of
Manhattan to be in his office at 6:45
every morning and go out every night of
the week with companies or other money
managers to try
I figure out ways of beating the market
you know that's you know legends do
something different but you know these
are some of the characteristics I look
for this by the way slide deck is
available to you in hardcopy
and 610 you want them through the
administration of the University you can
get them but if numbers don't speak to
you in other words were you know Ben
Graham wrote a book called the
intelligent investor in 1954 and in the
book he hypothesized that analysts
evaluate management twice in the process
once through the numbers in other words
when you look at a company the company
is growing in X and return on investment
is why and profit margins or whatever
and returning capital whatever those are
financial statistics resulting from the
efforts of management so you want to
look at the financials but also you want
to look at the management face to face
and try to assess whether they
understand their business properly
whether they have the right moral
compass whether the people you want to
invest in and bet on so I think if you
don't like working with numbers and you
don't like working with people my guess
is the area security analysis might not
be that appealing to you if you like
working with numbers that would be
something then that would be important
I found a tremendous amount of interest
in the hedge fund industry
over the last five or six years but I
want you to know it's not a one-way
street so what I arrayed this was an
article written in Fortune magazine in
1900 and I think 70 or 71 by a very very
distinguished writer her name is Carol
Loomis she actually writes a lot of the
auntie report stuff or Warren Buffett
and she couldn't have been more wrong
because this article was written to
wring the death Knoll for the hedge fund
industry after the 6870 bear market and
as you look at that other than a mutual
fund that Mary and I Michael Steinhardt
everyone got pretty severely beat up
okay but today I could name 50 hedge
funds that are over ten billion dollars
so the argument that the industry was
all
/ was totally wrong you know and that is
most striking to me
the Lord is hedge fund in 1968 with 220
million dollars
startups are starting up with billions
of dollars today so it's a it's a
cyclical growth industry and if you
produce two returns you'll grow when if
you don't you'll atrophy it's a little
bit like Darwinism right survival of the
fittest but so don't think if you go
into the business that it's just up up
up up and no he cups along the way every
business as he cups along the way and
what separates the men from the boys is
how you doing periods of adversity and
how you deal with it in the last 20
years I've had three years where I've
had losses my investors difficult it's
hard to pay you people you lose certain
amount of self-esteem because you've got
the environment wrong but I always stuck
around to fight my way out of the hole
and come back and I think it's important
that you understand it's cyclical now
let me take a little bit about omega2
before getting into the investment
outlook I tried I'm trying in this brief
talk to touch on a number of different
subjects to see you know what an
interest you the students probably most
interest in getting a job upon
graduation so we talked a little bit
about philosophy and technique to the
corporation that you ought to insure one
know what's gonna happen the economy may
be what's happening interest rates so
I'm gonna try to touch a little bit of
everything and then let the Q&A to drill
down to where you're most interested so
but I talked a little bit about what
mega does where an equity oriented hedge
fund with a we call a macro capability
macro is distinguished from equities
macro being you know bonds currency
commodities so we have a little bit of
an overlay we manage about 6.6 billion
dollars in total we have 40 individuals
of the firm about 14 of which are
partners in the so-called incentive
carry that we earn if we do well we try
to make money for our investors in five
different ways know one way is more
important the other way but I say the
largest return has come from the third
element on the list
I see we didn't have a slide on that but
the five ways we make money are number
one basically is market direction I
don't care how smart you are a rising
tide lifts all the ships a receding tide
lowers all the ships so we spent a lot
of time at Omega my partner Steve
Einhorn is vice chair in the firm
studying the economy the Fed market
valuation and tried to determine whether
the stock market's undervalued going up
or overvalued going down because that
determines our exposure to risk assets
stocks and are higher risk assets that
is cash is short-term bonds and so if
you think the markets going down you
want to be defensive Lee's postured if
you think the markets going up you want
to be reasonably fully invested number
one number two we do a lot of work in
the area of asset allocation we look at
stocks versus bonds and within bonds we
would look at government bonds versus
industrial bonds high-yield bonds and
structured corporate credit and we're
trying constantly whether it's United
States Canada or Western Europe when we
look at all these different markets to
try and find what I refer to as a straw
hat in the winter during the winter
people don't buy straw hats they buy
them in the summer so it stands to
reason if they're not buying something
it's at a favor it could be ten
potentially undervalued so we're looking
for the straw hats in the winter where
we think something can change buy them
in the winter and hope by the summer and
more recognized third where I spend the
bulk of my own personal time is
undervalued stocks on the long side we
visit companies we knock on doors we
quiz management's we study industry
statistics study valuation and try to
determine whether a stock is mispriced
we buy it if we think it's undervalued
and with patient capital we'll wait for
the market to recognize what we think we
recognize stock to appreciate and then
move on to the next undervalued security
fourthly which distinguishes the hedge
fund from a mutual fund is two things in
egregiously - rupture most mutual funds
manage for 1% or less and hedge funds
charges similar to larger fee and get a
percentage of the ups and the other
thing to distinguish them is you could
sell stocks short and the best way to
understand that
you sell something you don't own because
you think it's overvalued and you buy
one of the Kleins in price and cover
your short so you can only make money
long it can make money short and you
participate with the investor in a share
of the profits and finally we do a
certain amount of what I call macro
investing where we have might have a
view of interest rates so we no longer
shorter bonds we can go longer short
commodity like oil oil is currently $100
a barrel and we develop his view of the
global economy is slowing oil is gonna
be an excess supply that we think the
price could drop to 80
they might short well with 100 the idea
of buying it at 80 we might buy it 100
be think it's going 220 we do a lot of
supply demand work in that regard and so
it could be currency
it could be commodities it could be
bonds and so we try this is what we try
to do for 20 years our returns have been
39% net of all fees to the investor
which is approximately 550 basis points
in excess to the sp500 and we've done
that with an average net long position
of about 70% so we've been less than
fully invested and of its achieved the
return five or fifty basis points in
excess of the market now it gets a
little more difficult to talk about the
investment outlook which I think trunk
of the audience is more interested in
and I'm really kind of an information
because I've been very optimistic the
last two and a half years but I'm
beginning to come a bit less optimistic
rather than overwhelming with the
specific forecast I'd like to show you
my methodology because if some of the
things I'm looking at don't resonate you
is some of the kind of analysis we're
doing again I should tell you something
about the right career path to pursue
but the the great Warren Buffett once
observed that forecasts of the future
tell you more about the forecaster than
they tell you about the future so I
think I've told you a bit about myself
but I did not mention
that of the 6.6 billion that we manage
roughly a quarter of that is the capital
of the partners of the firm so Warren
Buffett has popularized this notion he
eats his own cooking we that are on
cooking because if we lose money we're
gonna lose more than anyone loses
because of our investment that we make
more we make more than anyone makes
because of our investment so in a sense
we have a complete alignment of interest
we live in very exciting times but I
have to say the message I'm giving
people now which is a little bit
different I've been giving last two and
a half years is I think that I think the
stock market is in a zone of fair
valuation notwithstanding the large
number of tail risks out there and every
forecast of market view is based upon
certain assumptions so I'm gonna tell
you what mine are and then I'm going to
develop my view with more detail and
more statistical substantiation my first
assumption is the economy continues to
grow albeit a slow subpar rate of about
2% and that we don't fall into a
recession in the next 12 months that's
very important because most every
recession I know of is preceded by a
bear market so if we don't have a
recession the likelihood of a bear
market I think is small secondly and
this has taken a lot of brainpower from
a lot of people and that is that the ECB
European Central Bank continues to act
to stabilize the financial system in
Europe much the way our Fed did so in
the United States and that these
eurozone governments particularly
Germany act in a cooperative way to fund
weak European sovereign debt needs and
further the European banks raised the
costly capital they have to raise shed
troubled loans to opportunist to catch
funds like ourselves and the ECB takes
off troubled loans and the banks balance
sheets they earn money with a positive
slope EO curve and that in conjunction
the passage of time the European finance
institutions will earn their way out of
the hole they're in and let me just say
on that score
they've been two schools of thought the
last two years on Europe one school of
thought has been has been that the
problem is so complex so difficult to
understand that exceeds one's bandwidth
and they don't want to invest because
they think the kind of the consequence
is so catastrophic the second school of
thought which I've pursued was 45 years
of investing when everybody's teeth is
Nanchang gnashing about a problem
everybody believes something if it hits
is so catastrophic in its impact
it generally doesn't hit so maybe it was
an easy way out but what I've been
saying to myself is that the the the
breakup of the euro and the eurozone is
so catastrophic in its impact over
Europe that the ECB the IMF which is 70%
funded by the United States Germany
France China Japan will all chip in to
do what they have to do to kick the can
down the road and we will not have a
catastrophic outcome in Europe that are
still my belief and when people start to
think more of them along those ways you
know if you listen to what Germany is
saying today
first what Germany was saying a year ago
it's totally different because Germany
understands if the Euro breaks apart
their major you loser why because if the
Euro breaks apart and the Dutch Marx
starts trading a separate currency it'll
go to a level like the Swiss franc where
Germany will not be able to export
anything competitively so it's their
interest to keep the eurozone together
it's more complicated in United States
because United States we had one central
bank in Europe you have 17 members of
the EU each with their own kind of views
so it's more difficult to bring
everybody together and the third
assumption I'm making which I think it's
being challenged right now is that China
is in the midst of a soft landing not a
hard landing and that we'll have growth
in real terms in China of somewhere
between six and seven percent and it has
to be watched very very carefully the
Chinese government I think is in the
early stages of significant easing
they cannot afford a significant
economic slowly on a recession because
of the potential for social unrest in
the country the best way to think about
the problem China face is very simple
it's a nation of 800 million farmers
that only needs 200 million farmers and
those 600 million people that leave the
farm start to move into cities and they
have to have employment and if they
don't have employment you can have
social unrest so the biggest challenge
the government there is to find jobs for
25 million more people every year and
that's what they're working on
so my principal conclusions in the
equity market are driven or for these
observations and all my discussion that
follows justifies these statements no
recession the forecast horizon monetary
policy accommodative valuation a
reasonable investors of the wrist okay
and the conclusion I had then I got
quoted in this way and TV where stocks
are the best house in the financial
asset neighborhood it's not clear
whether it's a good or bad neighborhood
and I still believe that by the way so
the first thing let's talk a little bit
about the economy because I think a
picture's worth a thousand words
and basically as you can see from the
MIL column the average economic
expansion when one gets going basically
is lasts about five years 60 months now
I'm not here to debate whether this
expansions would be longer or shorter
than average but if I had to debate that
I would argue that a like likely be
longer than average because there's so
many sectors of the economy are still
operating below potential given the
severity of the recession of a wait so
autos are just starting to come back
still I think below trend the man
housing is way depressed way below
normalize the man
retail sales still below normalize
demand so I think as I said before most
recessions are preceded by bear markets
if we're right there were about a little
bit past the midpoint to this economic
expansion in that logical expected
significant market decline
the reasons for a relative optimist in
the economy or in this slide you know
we're all we're unhappy that employment
is not growing four or five hundred
thousand a month but we should
understand it is still growing its
growing subpar excuse me a lot of
reasons we can discuss later but
employment is improving and the average
monthly increase has been somewhere
around one hundred and forty to fifty
thousand there's still pent-up demand
the consumer sector the consumers
balance sheet has been improving as
they've pursued conservative financial
policies residential investment is way
below trend you know housing starts away
below normalize demand and I won't read
every one of these factors but I think
these are our reasons why we stand
before you I stand before you expecting
economic growth to continue our economic
framework is on this exhibit
we're expecting something between two
and two and a half percent growth and
basically it's not a Buell --nt it's not
a feel-good environment but nonetheless
it's an environment of a growth the
reason I say it's not a feel-good
environment and you should understand
these statistics in the US economy
typically the labor force remember
people seeking employment grows about
one percent a year the productivity of
the labor force grows about two percent
a year so you need around three percent
growth in real terms to make a dent or
even to keep unemployment level and
we're not growing at that rate we're
growing at a very sluggish subpar rate
you can argue for the different reasons
the need for governments to delever and
get their house in order given the size
of it but a deficit the uncertainty that
exists in America over the fiscal cliff
and the tax regime and perhaps
anti-business policies being practiced
by some we're not going to go there to
progressively and so you know whatever
the case they beat the economy is
growing but it's not a feel-good economy
because the growth is not rapid enough
to reduce the level of unemployment the
economy
giving you some support very important
air to the economy to both the consumer
and consumer psychology is housing and
you see the really the ingredients for a
decent-size recovery and housing
activity affordability is near record
high that's the top left-hand slide
home price is two disposable income is
running their record low levels so
houses are cheap in fact the value of a
home is a function the capitalized cost
of renting rents have gone up much more
relative to house prices and so now it's
actually cheaper to buy a home and to
rent but people have not been doing it
aggressively yet because one of the most
important expenditures they make in
their lifetime is a home purchase and
the extent that they're not confident
that the home prices are bottomed out
they don't want to make that jump that
leap but as they start to see evidence
of past prices bottoming out and in
certain areas you react that you back
into bidding contests there'll be more
optimistic so homeownership is declined
to very low levels rent as a percentage
the mortgage payment is at a record high
again and it's cheaper to now to buy
than to rent and you can see existing
home prices are starting to rise build
their confidence is rising and housing
inventory has come down over the last a
few years and a lot of sectors the
economy over sexist inventory has been
absorbed so the conditions are right for
housing I think that's important
underpinning to the economy the second
area worth talking about is the Fed and
when Mary and I came to Wall Street 45
years ago there was a very trite but
very correct statement that was the
central bank or a Federal Reserve Board
wrote the market letter for Wall Street
when the Fed was tightening it was
restrictive and negative the market when
the Fed was easy it was positive well
it's not the US Fed but a central banks
all over the world are telling you they
want more growth are willing to risk
more inflation they want more employment
and they're driving interest rates down
to relatively non competitive levels so
here you look at money supply growth
exploded over the last couple of years
the ferries our balance sheet has
exploded as they've take
loans onto their books off the banks to
give the banks more ability to lend to
the private sector and we're dealing
with a federal funds rate that has been
zero now for a couple years and just
recently Fed Chairman Bernanke spoke and
held that the prospect that the interest
rates will remain in the short end the
zero for a couple more years then you
look around the world this is the ECB
balance sheet the ECB balance she's a
percentage of the GDP Bank of Japan
balance sheet Ballinger pay and balance
sheet as a percentage GDP Bank of
England balance sheet and there's a
percentage in GDP and the message is all
the same there's been 250 ease things by
central banks all over the world and my
guess is a China is in the very early
stages of their easing and that's got to
be viewed positively another common
sense way of explaining it I may say
this later and I'll try to remember not
to repeat myself but basically all of us
in this audience to varying degrees have
a challenge of investing our financial
assets some have little they go to
school you're getting an education some
have more than a little but what are
your choices today your choices are
basically cash which is zero US
government bonds which I'll discuss in a
little while is about one and a half one
point six percent hardly a positive
return in for taxes and a negative
return after inflation can be high-yield
bonds I'll show you in a little while
that they've traumatically been really
priced or there's common stocks as we go
through each of these alternatives in
the next few minutes you'll see why I
say the stocks are the best house in the
financial asset neighborhood okay now
very very important to any value
investor is where you're getting into
the market is you could be very right on
your stock pick but wrong on your entry
point and not make any money so I try to
give you where we are today in the
market versus historical perspective so
for the last 50 years and the 2010 the
SP multiple averaged about 15 times
fourteen point nine and in that period
of time when the SP multiple average
fourteen point nine the 10-year US
government bond they come in to the
right average 6.67 percent well here we
are the markets about thirteen and a
half times the estimate of earnings
roughly ten percent below its long-term
average
but the US government bond at 1.6% is
almost a quarter of its long-term
average so p/e ratios relative interest
rates are quite low extraordinarily low
when the inflation rate in the country
ranged between 1 and 3 percent the
multiple in the S&P was actually close
to 17 so I look at this exhibit against
a span of time stocks are cheap against
their history they're cheap very cheap
against interest rates and they're very
cheap against inflation I think the
stock market is suggesting and it's
probably a good suggestion and that
we're probably going to be looking at
higher interest rates over the next few
years and slower economic growth versus
history but the extent that's being
discounted that's a plus for the market
because you're buying into something
already discounts a conservative set of
assumptions they'll give you a parallel
in the year 2000 the last bubble that
was in technology stocks in 2000 the
cisco was selling it a hundred times the
analysts estimate of earnings okay it
had no dividend so the yield was zero
and US government bond rates were six
and a half percent fast forward 12 years
today
Cisco is 10 times the estimate of
analyst earnings down from 100 times
stock yields 3% versus zero and ten
years at one point six down for six and
a half so you can now buy Cisco which is
a growing corporation you could debate
the growth rate that yields twice what
10-year government bonds are yielding
okay and a multiple that's one tenth of
what it was 12 years ago so evaluation
looks appealing secondly I don't believe
the returns will be a Zebulon going
forward as this historical numbers are
suggested but whenever you bought into
the stock market and the range of 12 to
14 times earnings where you are now the
return one year later was about 15
percent three years later average 16
percent per annum and five years later
average 15 percent so we're buying in an
historical context where returns
prospectively are very attractive for
reasons that I'll discuss later there's
always a dark side to everything I don't
think the returns will be nearly as
attractive as they've been historically
going forward now I mentioned about
stocks being the best house
Angela said nay but I find this chart
very interesting and Omega we made a
great deal of money in 2010-2011 and
partly this year in the high-yield bond
market if you look at this Bloomberg
chart in November of 2008 it was a once
I think in a lifetime I hope because the
suffering and the pain you go through in
those periods so dramatic you don't want
to live through it again but I certainly
would say safely he was once in a
generation opportunity in high-yield the
high-yield mark was 25 percent you could
buy senior securities in the capital
structure to company yielding 25 percent
the hundred-year returned the equity
market was 10 percent to buying a senior
security that was yielding two and a
half times with the long-term return the
equity markets been well if you look at
the bottom a footnote I guess I had a
sport that could be using and finding
where it gets on the screen here is
right there when the high yield index
was 25% the SP multiple was 13.9 the
high yield index is now sub 7% and the
multiple the market is not maturely
different than it was in 2008 now we're
getting towards cyclical peak earnings
versus trough earnings but nonetheless
the long did the high-yield bond is
about a quarter of its peak yet the
multiple in the market is not
substantially different than when high
yield was four times greater and anyone
who follows the high-yield market with
any credit spreads are historically very
tight and yields were historically very
very low so that once-in-a-generation
opportunity is gone then here Mary and I
always had a favorite professor that
shaped and nurtured our interest in
security analysis and then was Professor
Roger Murray at Columbia and I can
remember like it yesterday unfortunately
wasn't yesterday about 45 years ago we
told the class 1958 was a famous year in
the equity market
he then went on to explain 1958 was the
year of the yield reversal prior to 1958
stocks yielded more than bonds you were
coming out of World War two there was a
great fear of a post-world War recession
depression let down and then beginning
in 1958 when people saw the economy
growing and company is growing and Sears
Roebuck was opening up a store in the
burbs virtually every week the more I
could bought into the concept of Total
Return meaning the investors boring the
concept of Total Return they did the
return of stock is not just a dividend
but it's a dividend couple with the
growth in the dividend
well we've turned back over fifty years
of history pudgy as you can see from
this chart I put this together
over half the stocks in the S&P 500 now
yield more than bonds definitely but
government bonds are unofficially
depressed by the feds you know you know
policies but this is higher there was in
2008 which was an important mark a
bottom on 45 percent and you looked back
over the years nothing like we are now
so you could find many many many many
stocks and I hope you're invested in
club that's managing Mario's money which
he knows will never get back or the
other money in the university and your
investment club activities that you're
seeing many many stocks that are
yielding substantially in excess of
bonds and these are growing companies
now I haven't it's probably somewhat
been appropriately quoted I should
elaborate I was correctly quoted but
probably an inappropriate statement but
I made a comment about six months ago on
TV that I wouldn't be caught dead
owning a US government bonds and that's
coming out yeah it's not Atlantis David
it's a correct statement by the way but
you know too strong I meant by that it's
not that I questioned the US
government's ability to pay us back
they'll be fine they'll pay you back but
the you're just not being compensated
for the risk so I felt and coming upon
me to explain my position and
historically if you look at the 10-year
US government bond is yield in line with
nominal GDP nominal GDP is the summation
of real growth and inflation so if you
say to yourself that with the world we
live in be something like two to three
percent real growth and two to three
percent inflation that means nominal or
top-line GDP we just say in looking at a
company sales and that we growing
somewhere between four and six percent
per annum keep in mind that four percent
we're not gonna absorb more and
unemployed people so there will be
social policy you will be tilted towards
trying to generate
more economic growth well if history
repeats itself and the tenured
government bond goes back to in nominal
GDP is that means in a few years time
when we get out of this soup in the
economy that they tenured government
bond will be four or five or six percent
well this is bond arithmetic I printed
this to get it up here in time when the
ten-year was one and a half percent I
think it's now about 1/7 but if we go
for one and a half to four in three
years including your coupon
you've lost 11 percent of your money the
ghost of morning after 5:00 you go
sixteen percent of your money because
the warning after 6:00 that goes to 21
percent of money now the maximum
marginal tax rate is 35% so if you buy a
bond the one half percent you keep 65
percent leaving out state taxes for the
moment you really get an after-tax
return about one percent doesn't wash
I think the capital is being confiscated
so I have no particular interest in
government bonds as an alternative
common stocks now the last thing I want
to mention is it kind of comes in the
world of contrary opinion you know it's
an expression which those of you who
come to Wall Street will come to respect
and understand and that is the stock
market does whatever its guide do to
confound the largest group of investors
I mean when everybody's complacent and
comfortable in their forecasts the guys
like me the market does something that
surprised you well in the last five
years we've seen a significant
de-risking by the public and by
institutions of their equity ownership
so what would the Payne trade be the
surprise would be has it happened this
year the market goes up because
everybody that is expecting the market
that go down so you look here and you
see again every year in the last five
years significant selling of equity
funds by the public what are they doing
they're buying bond funds even though
the markets up about fourteen or fifteen
percent this year what are they doing
they continuing to liquidate then you
look at the pension fund sector pension
funds have gone from 60% equities to
near 50 most of them have actuarial
assumptions on their pension plan of
earning seven or eight percent a year
you can't do it in fixed income of my
opinion it's either going to be real
estate private equity or
equities and then you look here at the
public they've gone from 29% of their
financial assets and equities down to
around 20 and they're holding of stock
funds of decline and the holding of bond
funds and risen so I say the pain trade
to the public is if the market went up
and you know not not going down now I
don't want to stand here in front of you
and appear like the village idiot
because I'm not the economy faces a
significant number of issues that we
have to deal with and one is the
so-called fiscal cliff if nothing
happens
there's legislative tax increases and
expenditure cuts that hit the economy
Jan 1 of 576 billion dollars which is a
little bit less than 4% of GDP now if we
continue to have gridlock in government
resulting from the fact that Republicans
and Democrats can't stand each other
they don't want to talk to each other
they don't negotiate we could have a
serious setback I refuse to believe that
that dump you know the end of the day
it's the same group it didn't like each
other in 2008 but they did with had to
do in terms of legislation to get the
economy out of this sharp dive so I
think rather than push us into a
dramatic recession that there'll be
compromises but it's not a hundred
percent clear that it's going to happen
so I think there's something that we
have to kind of think about and worry
about I have a firm view about the
coming election we can talk about the
late in Cuba day but that's just a
personal opinion it's a bad like talking
about abortion I guess a lot of people
with different opinions second I'm very
concerned about the huge buildup of
federal debt just common sense kind of
observation the nation was founded in
1776 we had no debt we now have 16
trillion of federal debt so we went from
1776 to 2012 they go from zero to 16
trillion that's growing up by over a
trillion dollars a year now it's
unsustainable we have to deal with this
this president the Commission
simpson-bowles they come up with some
credible ideas but we've done nothing
with them but I think unless we move
in this area I think it's going to be a
significant issue and while we're not
Greece we can have similar type problems
not the same degree if we don't start
dealing with our problems as you can see
what's happening to ad debt relative the
size of our economy
and I think that's a problem and lastly
there is a huge legislated tax increases
on the horizon not particularly friendly
towards capital formation the current
top tax rate on dividends of 15 percent
I guess you could see the right there 15
if Obama has his way it's almost a
tripling the dividend tax increase
something's going to happen and there's
gonna be about nine point or 50% or so
increase in the tax rate in capital
games and you know if you lower the
after-tax return on investing you
basically get and lower the amount of
investment that's taking place so we
have to resolve these issues which
basically confront us and probably
nothing's gonna happen until November
6th and we see who the leader the
country is and who controls Congress so
these are factors we have to worry about
now my observation was to go back early
into my career my horatio out of story I
say they've a big smile and a certain
sense of modesty but I got my MBA from
Columbia on January 31st of 1967 I had a
child why was its Business School was
six months old my graduated I had no
money in the bank National Defense
Education Act stood alone to repay so
those of you in the gabelli School of
Business I'm sure that you've learned
that if you have an L a liability and no
ask that you have a negative net worth
okay I hope you learned that and
basically I had no choice but to go to
work immediately so the very next day
February 1st of 1967 I started my close
to 25 year career at Goldman Sachs well
in February 1st of 1967 the Dow was
roughly 850 and lo and behold 15 years
later it was 850
I made my money by finding things that
were very cheap so that were at seven
hundred ow or the equivalent and crying
it out even though the overall mark was
going nowhere and I could very well
appreciate a scenario where because of
the need of governments around the world
that delever
and to get their financial house in
order that the next few years we could
remain in a trophy environment as we
deal with the fiscal cliff as we deal
with the huge deficit issues and the
market sees the need to deal with them
in intelligent fashion so I'm prepared
you know it's hard for me you folks are
young you know we're early 20s late
teens whatever that you could live
through another three years of this as I
said at the beginning you know my life
expected 82 I mean another three years
of nothing kind of market it's gonna be
very painful to me but I'm gonna do it
I'm gonna work at it because this is
what I love doing this is what I have an
obligation to do but I took somebody's
money I got a manager intelligently and
properly now I am a value investor and
somebody over lunch is what is the value
invest of me and what it means to me is
I want more for less so when you look at
the stock market basically the S&P 500
is an index of 500 companies on average
it grows about 5% per annum on average
it's giving about 2% it sells a little
over two times the book value of the 500
companies in the index it has debt about
35% of its capital its debt to equity
plus debt okay it original equity
currently is about 16% normally it's
close to 14 to 15 and the p/e ratio for
that statistical knowledge is 13 1/2
times so as a value investor I'm looking
for companies that are growing more
rapidly that sell it a lower multiple or
have more dividend yield than the market
a lower valuation or maybe give me a lot
more asset value versus the value that
I'm paying for it and that's to me when
a value investor is all about it so you
could be value investing by Apple
Computer Apple sitting 120 billion
dollars in cash it sells at 12 and a
half times earnings or is 50
and equity and all the equities excess
capital in the balance sheet but if you
have a view about growth I think growth
won't be like it's been the last few
years but I think they'll grow 20% year
in next few years so it's growing four
times the market so I'm going to
slightly lower the market multiple you
have to accept technology risk don't
forget you know three years ago we were
standing here we'd be talking about
wearing a thumbs on the blackberry and
now blackberry subscriber base the
United States of America is dropping in
a rate of 50 percent per annum they've
been knocked out
I joined Xerox said of hunt to college
my first job basically it was all about
American photocopy and you don't hear
about them anymore zorag Rafi knocked
them out you know in the world of
technology some of these innovation is
somebody's obsolescence so you have to
make that judgment call but this is what
a value investor does it looks for more
for less now I I said at the outset that
I was becoming a little bit less
sanguine you know sometimes you're you
know you're in the midst of changing of
you adjusting of you and you're speaking
at the wrong time you know the more time
to think things through
but basically firstly the market now at
this level that has got to if the result
of last week's rallies about 13 1/2
times earnings that has been the upper
end of the PT range in the market for
the last three years so it's at the
upper end the range of less three years
secondly the third quarter this year
that will give you a little bit more
short-term view the third quarter this
year will be the first down quarter
year-over-year since the third quarter
of 2009 so the rate of increase in
corporate profits is entman ameliorating
and actually could very well be down for
a while and that's a factor and as we
get closer and closer at the end of the
year the fiscal cliff issues thought to
loom larger and I think there's huge
uncertainty regarding tax policy that I
mentioned before and I first to admit
that the China is slowing
more than expected it's has to be
watched very very carefully and finally
the ECB well they've taken important
steps there's a lot more things they
have to do regarding fiscal integration
Bank sector union and stuff like that so
I think we you know we I think we've
adjusted ourselves now to a level of
fair valuation so I'd say first thing I
think the markets got five percent up
two percent down but you know I intend
to follow the advice of author burns he
was a professor teaching PhDs at
Columbia and one of the students upon
graduation went to professor and said
professor burns do you have any advice
to me now that I'm graduating and his
advice was for Caswell but above well
forecast often so right now I'd say
stocks are the best Houston financial
asset neighborhood I try to develop the
reasoning why I think near-term as much
risk the market is reward but I do
believe that properly selected by
gabelli maybe in Cooperman we can make
money for you in the market that we see
but I hope I touched on things that
interest you if I was industrious in the
audience I'd like it long-term money and
if I had access to public markets so I
think it's just rates or at the
generation lows they don't belong here
when I look at the fiscal condition in
the country and I would plan on the US
economy continue to grow at a modest
pace if I was a student getting ready to
go out to pursue my career is just get
the best education you can get the best
grades you can get back through
community service try to distinguish
your resume from the next person because
you're in a very competitive environment
and you just want to strengthen your
condensers to ever extend you can and
I'm gonna stop here and then take
questions
thank know we have time for only a
couple of questions because mr. Koopman
has to be on his way to TF green if he
doesn't get out of here in about five
minutes oh I'm so Jersey so I don't want
to do that so I think we have missed a
juror who are these guys that's the joy
we also have mics but all right my name
is Dan Walt summer student fund manager
here Roger Williams mr. Cooperman first
question you put a lot of Reliance
towards fundamental analysis when
valuing out the intrinsic value of
companies and then base that off of the
fair market value what are some of the
key indicators that you base those
decisions off of and how much reliance
do you put towards behavioral analysis I
put a lot of Reliance my behavior but no
I'm very analytical try my team derives
models revenues costs earnings growth
rates market position growth in the
market so on and so forth and we have a
certain view of what growth rate is
worth and if it's selling you know
Graham and Dodd hypothesized in the book
security analysis that every security
had a ban of intrinsic value in the job
of the security analyst and Alice an
analyst is to recommend securities that
are basically selling below that ban of
intrinsic value which is the result of
growth rates returns cash flow
generation the most important thing to
me is free cash flow because unless the
company's generating free cash flow
there's nothing they have no luxury of
pursuing other alternatives so with that
free cash flow they can invest in their
business they can buy back equity they
can pay dividends that's the elixir that
keeps things going so I say free cash
flow most important to me in a good
industry with honest management honest
management I would not knowingly invest
with somebody was dishonest
now I've invested knowingly with
incompetent people because something was
just too cheap to ignore but more often
not you know there's something
expression have you go to bed with dogs
you wake up with fleas but uh my I'm a
little bit like Warren Buffett except
about a lot less zeros in the sense that
you know he he believes in investing
with a well-run company in fact his
favorite expression was he likes to
invest in companies
they can manage by an idiot because
sooner or later an idiot will be running
him so that's what he said that's pretty
humorous and nobody quite that one but
anyway I'd like to invest in businesses
that are cash flow generators that are
run by capable management where the
management is properly incentivized to
do the heavy lifting and I benefit from
their hard work so the best case in
point the fund name sandy goddess Minh
and terrific guy runs first Manhattan he
was an investor with Berkshire Hathaway
for I don't know 50 years he moved out
of the partnership when Morneau hung
around this partnership and kept his
invest in Berkshire Hathaway I think
he's worth three or four billion dollars
and having all the heavy lifting done by
Warren that's the essence of investing
fine a well-run company and back to
jockey make sure he's properly
compensated and benefit from his
performance or up performance another
question behind more than happy to take
you late
I'm Mike Densmore most the way a student
fund manager
I was wondering during your experience
and investing in China how did you get
around issues of company transparent a
different question I have no investments
in China right I have excuse me I
dropped something and I want a litter up
the floor here I have one investment in
Asia
I own a ia the Asian Insurance Company
which is growing quite rapidly used to
be controlled by AIG but in their
financial problems they spun it out to
the public so it's a rapidly growing
company in a very attractive valuation
but I'm not a big invest in China there
are enough companies in America Western
Europe Canada that I'm not as global as
some other people
after leaving Goldman why did you go off
and start Omega instead of taking a more
traditional route working for the
Treasury or another government agency I
know that's traditional basically I
would still be at Goldman Sachs I had a
lot of
them invigaron me high retire from
goldman for one reason i spent my first
23 years of the firm being part of or
running the research department then the
firm came to me in 1989 I had been
agitating the prior five or six years
telling Goldman management that they
were making a mistake not being in the
money management business and so they
came to me in 1989 and said you know you
were right we were wrong would you build
us an asset management business and so I
left research to start goldman sachs
asset management i was chairman and CEO
but after a relatively short period of
time i saw that the firm's objectives
and my objectives didn't mesh and this
is not being critical goldman i had 25
glorious years there's a great firm but
goldman understood assets and the
management tines fee equal revenue so
they wanted to to manage as much money
they can humanly get the hands on
because that would grow the business and
my objective was very different
I wanted to co-invest what the investors
have my money alongside of them and
manage a rational sum of money where I
can deliver good returns so after a year
of doing what Goldman want than me do I
saw that they wanted me on the road
making marketing presentations gathering
a lot of assets starting new product
lines you know goldman and i started the
first neutral fund the goldman sachs
since the depression called the GS
capital growth fund they wouldn't put
their name on it because john Weinberg
who's passed away his father saved the
firm's during the Great Depression if
you read chapter 2 John ganha Kenneth
Galbraith book and the Great Crash he
says in Goldman Sachs we trust goldman
came out with some mutual funds right at
the top of 1929 they went to near 0 and
he did not want goldman to be in the
mutual fund business now if you open up
the Wall Street Journal you'll see 40 or
50 different funds that Goldman Sachs is
selling to the public so I wanted to be
in a different kind of business so I
retired I'm proud to say I managed four
hundred million dollars for goldman
sachs
now Willy Sutton said he asked him why
he robbed the banks he said that's where
the money is so if your choice was going
at the money man your business where you
mad somebody's money for one percent or
you could have some variation of 1 or 2
percent and 20 percent and you want to
be more entrepreneurial and you want
their money right with the investors you
know the hedge fund business was a more
logical route
me I don't that answers your question
again I powder for went to alum I want
to cover a broad range of subjects if I
could be of help to any of you as long
as it's not between 9:30 or for you
could feel free to reach out get this
presentation and I'd like to impart
whatever wisdom I sit on the board as
Mara does the Columbia Business School
and we like to work with young people
and try to give them career guidance and
help out and I'm sure you know Buffett
recently visited the business school and
everybody was kind of depressed about
was going on the environment he said if
you have a Columbia MBA and I'll say the
same for you that he said he'd give you
$100,000 now for 10% of your lifetime
earnings so I'm sure all your going to
be very successful and I'll take 10%
your lifetime earnings half of the
faculty staff administration of rogering
Zoomers thank you mr. Cooper
thank you so much
they belong